- You look so different
in all the things you do,
like Hunger Games, Vikings.
Everything you do, you look so different.
That's so cool.
You're a chameleon.
- Awww, thank you so much.
I mean especially for this,
like we're showing an arc
between when he's a young man
to up until he's 40 or something
with three or four kids.
I always like to switch it up if I can.
Actually I had a gift for you.
I was gonna bring this great necklace
and a box of chocolates, but I think--
(Whitney laughing drowns out Alexander)
- But I was like, "Maybe not."
(audience clapping and cheering)
You're funny.
- It was really nice, but...
- So wait, you also like
Nashville a lot, too,
because you're releasing
a country song, right?
- I am.
- Yes, you're working
on a record.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- [Whitney] Wow.
- [Kelly] So tell everybody.
- [Whitney] That's so cool.
- [Alexander] Thank you.
- [Kelly] Tell everybody about it.
- [Whitney] Wow.
- Awww, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
- I love it.
You sent this song, and I love it.
I love that you sound country.
I feel like a lot of country music now
is starting to depart
from what actual country
music sounds like.
- I love traditional country music.
I grew up listening to
the likes of George Strait
and everyone from that era.
Randomly, I had some time off of Vikings,
and I got on a plane,
and I was like, I'm gonna go to Nashville
and I'm gonna try to figure it out.
I had no plan whatsoever,
and while I was getting on the plane,
all these guys in black
attire come up to me.
I was like, these guys gotta be a band.
And he goes, "Hey man, I'm a
huge fan of Lone Survivor,"
which was a film I did awhile ago.
He's like, "What are
you doing in Nashville?"
And I was like, "Well,
I'm trying to figure out
how to do this country thing.
I wanna learn what it
takes to write a great song
and start from the ground up."
Turns out, they've played with you before.
It's Tully Kennedy and Kurt Allison,
who play with Jason Aldean.
- Great band.
- They're amazing.
So they've been producing me,
and I'm gonna release it.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- I just don't wanna look
back on my life when I'm 80
and wish I had done it.
- [Kelly] Regret not going for it.
- Exactly.
- And it sounds awesome.
- [Alexander] Thank
you so much. Thank you.
- Yeah, at first I was like,
"Oh, he sings country?"
And I was like, "Awesome."
And it wasn't that you were Canadian.
Canadians actually love country music.
- Got a huge country
music scene in Canada.
- I toured with Reba,
and literally it's like crazy up there.
They love it.
- Wow.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I love it.
- And like the hockey dressing rooms,
that's what we'd all be
listening to back then.
- That's intense.
I like country music
'cause there's a story.
- Yeah, yeah, 100%.
- There's a story they tell ya,
I'm gonna drive down to the gas station.
I'm gonna take a left.
(Alexander laughs)
- My dog's with me.
- You've got the whole,
- My dog is with me.
- You've got the thing.
It's a lot of details.
- He's got some painted-on jeans.
That's usually one. (laughs)
Yes, like awesome.
- I got the receipt.
I need to go return the
gift and get a new one,
and you're like, "Wow."
- [Alexander] It's very, very practical.
- Painted a picture here.
- I like a picture.
No, but congrats on Vikings.
- Oh, thank you.
- Do you just love doing it?
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Thanks. Thank you.
- Here's the thing I
love about your character
because I had seen it,
but I had no idea it was
based off a real character,
like a real life person.
- [Alexander] Yeah, yeah.
- I didn't know that.
- Björn Ironside was a real live Viking.
He was the first king of Sweden,
and he said that he was
the son of Ragnar Lothbrok,
who is kind of a mythological character
that we don't actually know if he existed.
I'm such a history buff.
I love that kind of stuff.
- I think it's cool.
- And by the way, I just
watched your Netflix special.
You're amazing.
- Thank you.
- So good.
(audience applauds)
- We've met before--
(audience cheering drowns out Alexander).
- I just realized that, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Thank you for making this about me.
- No, it was so good.
It was so good.
- Thank you. I agree.
- [Kelly] Speaking of Vikings,
(Alexander laughs)
- Wait, no, "I agree.
"I agree. I'm awesome."
- [Alexander] "Yes, yes, I'm awesome."
(laughing)
- So wait, do you think
that you would actually make a good Viking
after having to like...
'cause it's been kinda grueling.
I read how y'all shot this,
and how you regularly shoot.
It's like crazy hard.
- No, it really was one of
the most trying experiences
of my life.
No, I would make a terrible Viking.
I mean, it's not for
divas, that's for sure.
But it was a great experience.
I have a story.
They put a ton of makeup on
you and try to break you down
for the show.
- Welcome to being a woman
all the time.
(laughing)
- Welcome to being a woman.
- You know what?
It doesn't look like this, okay?
- [Whitney] No idea what that's like.
- That's a lot.
(Kelly talking drowns out Alexander)
- And there's times where,
just because it's so quick and demanding,
that you don't have time to put on makeup.
I'll never forget this one time.
I went down.
I was like, "Screw it.
I'm gonna do it myself."
And I just pull out this big clod of dirt,
and I stuck it all over my face,
and I realize after, it was horse (beep).
(audience gasps and groans)
- [Alexander] And I'm like,
- Oh, that is--
- That has been my life
for six years.
- That is the greatest story
I've ever heard on this show.
(audience applauds)
- Yeah.
Did you vomit?
- I didn't have time to take it off,
so I just--
- Oh my god!
- Just went through with it.
- By the way, your skin looks amazing.
(Alexander laughs)
- [Kelly] Maybe we should try it.
- I don't know.
- Hey, Shark Tank.
- I think there's a business here.
- Shark Tank, another gift to give you.
That's horri... You're very method.
(laughing)